un nom mais toute façon c'est pas avec
les chasseurs russes que vous allez
revenir au top herbert on va voir
comment vous pourriez revenir au top
on va faire une interview back to top
alors herbert léonard est ce que pour
revenir au top
vous seriez prêt à vous mettre nue sur
une pochette jamais à vous faire appeler
m6 herbert ça veut dire quoi même si
master dans ces mêmes années
why not à faire la première partie d'
elodie d'ekwa d'elodie frégé qui s'est
un peu de respect pour les vrais verts
je sais pas qui c'est est ce que vous
seriez prêt humbert pour revenir au top
a enregistré une version gay de pour le
plaisir
pourtant plus j'ai toujours dit que le
jour où je déciderai de d'arrêter de
chanter je sais pas quand ça viendra ni
si ça viendra je ferai une version x2 to
meet you are et
je crois qu'on va garder je vois que
c'est dessus c'était vraiment un sampler
que je vais garder mes retirer l'eau
chez vous vous imaginez ce que vous êtes
prêt pour revenir au top à faire un duo
avec des rappeurs ah oui oui oui j'adore
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à raconter
dans les émissions de télévision que
vous êtes tombé dans la drogue
je suis jamais tombé dans la drogue
alors je peux pas dire ça est ce que
vous seriez prêt à faire un lifting
donc je suis prêt à tout sauf à ça
d'accord est ce que vous seriez prêt à
dire du mal de michel drucker gente
humaine mais non non je peux pas non non
non il ya un moyen de revenir back it up
a aussi sa branche quand même s'ils
avouent faire naturaliser québécois non
à vous habiller moulant non plus vous
faire photographier dans voici avec
ophélie winter
si elle me prête c'est ça oui vous faire
teindre les cheveux je lui fais j'ai
fait deux ans pendant deux ans j'ai fait
notre dame de paris
ouais j'ai donc me léonard dans une
petite boîte et je vais frollo way et je
me suis fait teindre les cheveux pendant
deux ans au site est horrible je me fais
un plaisir extraordinaire à jouer les
méchants est ce que vous seriez prêt à
chanter la star ac pour revenir au top
ouais pour revenir au top non un meet up
alors l'histoire peut-être est-ce que
vous seriez prêt à prendre à louvain en
otage c'est un ami a tenté une vanne
contrebas fait où il est un ami
oui oui à soutenir dieudonné je pense
pas non acquitté ce plateau tout de
suite en faisant un énorme scandale pour
revenir au top pour revenir au top mais
je suis beaucoup trop modeste pour ça
non vous auriez près à quoi alors pour
revenir au top mais ma productrice a
toujours dit que je manqué d'ambition et
je pense qu'il a toujours eu raison
parce que j'ai jamais cherché à être
constamment au top quoi je sais pas
c'est pas seulement l'accident il ya
aussi un manque d'ambition vous pensez
quelque part oui certainement un jeu
cherche pas écraser tout le monde a
envie d'en changer maîtresse tous les
six mois pour faire la une de voici une
paix écoutez je me suis mariée très
récemment
les 37 ans et demi j'ai raconté pendant
les années que le mariage n'était pas
dans vos gènes et finalement vous avez
craqué kit période d'essai si pour des
raisons plus administratif cottereau
parce que l'amour n'a jamais manqué
ouais cette horreur je suis hébreu
l'album s'appelle
ces pièces alfie
on pourrait montrer une épaule
une épaule
et
j'accueille map